hey there i'm now a podcast czar
with a podcast empire
anyway i'm excited to announce the
latest addition to team coco
she is one of my all-time favorite
people the lovely the talented the sexy
nicole buyer
oh yes that is me nicole byer hello
conan that is right my podcast why won't
you date me
is now brought to you by team coco i'm
very excited i love it so much
and guess what okay my show is about
dating it's about bromance it's about
sex i've been single for a very long
time so i'm on a quest
to answer this question that keeps me up
at night oh
i want you to hate me and since you're
obviously an expert in the ways of love
i was hoping to get some dating advice
from you
conan what are your dating tips
uh well first uh you do not want to be
me
uh okay try to avoid being born
uh in a very uptight and rigid irish
catholic home
uh in boston that's a mistake if you
want to have a sexy
dating life okay that aside
uh if like me you're extremely
pale think about a tanning booth
before you ask a lady out okay be a much
better dresser than i was in my 20s i
wore my high school clothing all through
my 20s so
step up your game a little bit and guys
it's all about confidence
it's all about confidence so fake it
until you make it
so you've given me no dating tips for
myself
because i'm a black who dresses well so
i don't need the
the tanning salons and i don't need to
dress better because i already dress
good conan
i love it so basically what you're
saying is all i did was talk about my
own problems instead of helping you
yes that's another thing guys don't be
selfish and self-absorbed like i was
just there
i would say my dating tip for you uh
nicole
is uh sometimes you put very high
expectations on what a man's genitalia
should
yes look like if you put that out there
too much you're going to
frighten some very nice guys away
maybe don't have penises that should be
in the smithsonian museum
listen people eat organic for a reason
so i'm just making sure what i put in my
mouth is delightful and tasty for me
[Laughter]
then i have no dating tips for you
there's no way i can help you there's no
way i can
help you and by the way this is my
favorite thing no one uh makes me more
embarrassed uh than nicole buyer but i
have a really good time while it's
happening
so if you're looking for some more
nicole
uh plus other conan content you can hear
me as a guest on
why won't you date me where we discussed
all kinds of stuff
the use of the theragun which is
supposed to be used
on major muscle groups for runners after
a long run
nicole uses it for self-pleasuring and
many people think uh in the neighborhood
think that she's having major
construction done
in her bedroom